thanks for everyone who's stuck around
to the very end of the boot camp um we
have jonathan leak coming from tu berlin
to tell us about the second part of
optimization and sampling under synergy
yeah so thanks for uh thanks for having
me thanks for coming to this very last
talk of the week
um and yeah i'm going to continue on
what nasheed was talking about last talk
and try to give you a sense of the lead
theoretic underpinnings of what was
going on and what he was what he was
talking about
and as nasheed pointed out we have these
notes that kind of go into a lot more
detail about both of our talks on the
archive if you want to check those out
okay
so let me start off by kind of
discussing
excuse me talk a little bit so he had
one optimization problem in one sampling
problem okay so we had some permission n
by n matrix the eigenvalues were given
by a vector y
and we considered these two kind of
situations okay so let me let me look at
the sampling one first because it has
some of the definitions here so
we were sampling from the complex unit
sphere according to this density
okay from b on the unit sphere or there
was some equivalent way to state this
where we were sampling from from unitary
matrices so i'm going to use this u n to
denote the set of all unitary matrices
we sampled from this or also he used
this kind of script p1 to denote all the
rank 1 projections which is just exactly
what this kind of
orbit of the unitary group cuts out so
that's why you can just replace this
this p here
so that was one problem we considered
the other one was this uh minimum
eigenvalue problem where we kind of take
these expressions in the exponents and
just minimize over them
okay and as i think cole mentioned in
the previous talk this is sort of like
there's a way to view this as some kind
of limiting of this over here where you
put some temperature and limit it to
infinity i think
okay but the point is right these these
have like kind of a very symmetric right
there's a very symmetric story here
and that becomes even more clear when
you look at some theorems associated
with how
uh these things are proven or kind of
what's going on with these things so
uh nashith actually looked at the the
diagonal map applied to the orbit of y
but i'm actually going to look at the
diagonal map of the orbit applied to the
set of all rank 1 projections here
that's going to be the standard simplex
and over here we had a very similar
thing where we wanted to look at this
integral somehow we wanted to compute
this
and it ended up being some integral some
very similar integral over the standard
simplex in fact there was some you know
sum formula for this
um but the point is there there's kind
of a lot of similar things going on here
and we want to know what is the
underlying structure that unites these
problems and kind of makes everything
work
so the answer generally speaking is
symmetry and what that's going to mean
for us in this talk generally speaking
is it's going to be the action of some
group on the elements of some manifold
i'm going to use
green for group whatever group things
are happening in magenta for manifold
whenever manifold things are happening
so if you see those colors that's kind
of what's what the point of that is
okay and so the idea is right we have
some group element g
and some x in our manifold
and we're going to act on it we're going
to use this notation where g dot x just
means that g acts on x and so that's
going to be some function like this that
maps to some other point in our manner
like when we conjugate by unitary
matrices
we uh from you know we conjugate some
diagonal matrix with unitaries we get
some other permission matrix that has
the same eigenvalues
okay and some examples of this uh which
nishith kind of talked about are we have
maybe the
some discrete examples where the
symmetric group acts on the entries of
some vector
we have if we have some convex body we
can shift it within rn
by by adding some vector to all the
points
we can also rotate these bodies and then
as we saw in the previous slide maybe
the unitary group acts on the complex
unit sphere by multiplication like this
and the point of this or generally
speaking
what symmetry does is it sort of mods
out coincidental or duplicate
information coincidental being something
like let's say i care about you know the
volume of something like this or the
surface area okay it doesn't really
matter how i embed it into rn it doesn't
matter if i shift it around or rotate it
those things are sort of those the
coordinate the way it's sort of put into
rns coincidental that the information i
care about is the
sort of what's left over same with the
eigenvalues right we have all these
permission matrices with the same
eigenvalues by conjugation what's left
over when i remove the symmetry is uh
it's just the eigenvalues
so another thing maybe just you know
another way to look at this and this is
sort of the duplicate part here and this
is going to be some really maybe simple
version of of something like the hci z
formula um but let's suppose we have we
looked at the hypercube
okay this is not going to be like the
hci z formula at all but maybe it'll
give something you know some spirit of
it um and let's suppose we wanted to
compute some partition function on it
okay we have some function f and if i
you know if i want to sum up all the
values on the on the vertices of the
hypercube i really have to go and you
know compute each one of them and add
them all up right and there are two to
the n of those
but if this function was symmetric then
what i could do is i could sort of group
these vertices
right based on how many ones and how
many zeros they have okay and all the
all for the function f all these green
vertices would have the same value all
these orange vertices would have the
same value and the difference here is
between two to the n evaluations if i
don't know this symmetry or n plus one
okay so this is a very simple example
but maybe illustrates why you might
expect something like the hcic formula
to work
because you have some integral some kind
of like really big sum boiling down to
some small sum
okay and so then the question now that
we're going to try to answer is how does
this sort of thing duplicate information
these symmetries how you can reduce
things how how does this kind of really
relate to the two problems above
okay so let's
let's go for it so here's going to be
the outline so
the the lead theory part of this
is going to be mainly focused around
doing some computations for the unitary
group i'm going to assume very little
lee theory and so i'm going to try to
pretty economically talk about some of
the some of the lead theoretic concepts
that we need i'll try to generalize it a
little bit uh beyond the unitary group
and then we'll return to our two
problems uh and then i'll conclude
and the one comment i want to make here
about starting with the unitary group is
this sort of
means that we're we're kind of going
away
the stuff that avi and and michael
talked about in the morning were much
more related to groups like gln these
complex
uh lead groups and the groups that we're
going to be focusing on are going to be
compact lead groups which are sort of in
a different category and in fact if you
remember from michael's talk
often the unitary group was sort of was
sort of removed they were looking at
some normal minimization problem and the
unitary group preserves the norm so it
was sort of forgotten and what was left
over was these positive definite
matrices so we're going to be doing
something pretty different than that
we're going to be focusing on the
unitary group and these compact groups
so what is it it's the set of all n-by-n
complex matrices with this relation you
use star as the identity
okay it's a group as nishi talked about
and it also inherits a manifold
structure from the fact that it lies in
the space of n by n matrices
okay
and so
on the group side we get a lot of things
like this operations an identity element
maybe some homomorphisms on the manifold
side we can do calculus there are paths
smooth mappings between things
okay and we've got some kind of like
subgroups related uh so like we saw kind
of in earlier talks if you look at the
set of all invertible complex matrices
this is some subgroup of that and it's
compact
and also this happens to have some
abelian subgroup which is the set of all
diagonal matrices which look like this
so diagonal matrices with with compact
horse elements and diagonals
and but the most important kind of
feature of the unitary group that we're
going to focus on is the fact that this
group and manifold structure are
compatible so right if you what that
means is if you look at this
multiplication map
and you look at your inversion map
these are actually smooth maps so these
are you know a priori these are group
operations
but because we have this manifold
structure and because it's it's
compatible this is something you have to
prove but it's you know this is a
well-known fact at this point uh these
are actually smooth maps in the sense of
the manifold structure
so the question then is now what can we
get from this compatibility
okay
okay so
right we have this group structure we
have this manifold structure on un
and so let's start kind of just playing
around and see what we can what we can
do to combine them so the first thing is
right we know that this unitary group is
a manifold so what can we do well we
know it has tangent spaces at every
point and we can compute you know
elements of the tangent space by by
looking at paths in the group and taking
derivatives this is the standard way to
compute tangent space elements
okay but it's also a group and so we
have this distinguished tangent space of
the identity matrix so we're going to
sort of focus in on this one element of
the group and look at the tangent space
there
okay and let's so again i'm just trying
to feel out here trying to pretend that
i don't know what's about to happen okay
so let's suppose i want to start
computing this tangent space
okay so i'm going to look at any path
little short path in u n
that's this f of t here that passes
through the identity at t equals zero
and i'm gonna take the derivative to get
this x in the tangent space
okay i'm gonna use
either this or this notation so this is
the kind of standard notations for
computing these tangent vectors
okay and so you know i can do this right
i can i can write down this i have some
path i take the derivative i get some
tangent space element
you know all ten to space elements arise
in this way
but i've only sort of used the manifold
structure okay so what else can i do
well i can use the fact that we have
this group kind of rule right this is
the thing that defines the unitary group
okay and so using this fact the fact
that we have this group multiplication
and this identity here we can actually
say a lot more about the tangent space
in particular if you look at this
expression right what i'm going to do is
instead of just taking derivative of f
i'm going to look at the kind of this
the path multiplied it's by itself
conjugated at the same t variable
and since we know that for any t this is
a unitary group element
i know that this expression is always
identity so if i take derivative i'm
going to get 0
and now i can just apply the product
rule to this right so i take derivative
of this one plug in zero and then plug
in zero here and then on you know for
this one i take the derivative over here
this is just the leibniz rule
and the point is right i know at zero
this and this are both identity
and what that leaves is f prime of 0
plus f prime of 0 star
and i've used x to denote that and so i
get this expression
and what this says to us is that this
kind of gives us right this this group
rule that we had for unitaries sort of
descends down or i guess up or whatever
you want to call it to the tangent space
the identity
right this tangent space is now the set
of all skew hermitian matrices because i
have this relation right every tangent
space element arises from some
derivative of a path we can play this
game for any one of those and we get
this identity that
the conjugate transpose of x is equal to
minus x
and the point is here right this is some
group info was translated into extra
info on the tangent space and if you if
you've seen this before i mean like i
don't maybe all of you have i'm not
really sure um this is like this is a
very nice thing this is kind of one of
the nice things about about lead groups
in their in their tangent spaces you get
some really nice description of this
tangent space at the end
so now right what do we have we have
this tangent space which now we have a
really nice representation for or at
least some really nice description of it
okay
and we have this right these are
matrices our group is matrices so maybe
we can act upon our our tangent space
with these with these with this group of
matrices
so let's see what we can do with that
okay so this is what we saw last slide
okay and because we have matrices
what we can do now
is we can act on this tangent space via
conjugation okay conjugation is a group
operation just multiplication
and the reason why this is a reasonable
action is because okay here's my x from
the tangent space that i'm conjugating
by u
i'm looking at the conjugate transpose
and i sort of you know do a very basic
computation and i see that this ends up
just being negative of
the sort of conjugated x that i started
with so in fact this operation preserves
the tangent space it's still skew
permission after i do this okay so this
is like a valid action it it takes one
element of the tangent space and sends
it to another
okay and then the point here is that you
get some symmetries of the tangent space
coming from the group via this this
action which we're now always going to
denote by u.x
another nice thing about this which this
is you know kind of where we're gonna
we're gonna be going here if you think
about um
right if you think about this
conjugation action on this whole vector
space which is the tangent space
um it partitions this vector space into
orbits i mean this is always true
whenever you have a group action like
this
but these orbits right what are they
well this tangent space
it's not quite hermitian matrices but
it's almost they're skew hermitian
and i'll i'll mention this more more
concretely later but the uh the
connection between hermitian and skew
hermitian is just multiplication by i so
this is this is you know for all intents
and purposes this is essentially her
mission matrices
and so the point is now these unitary
conjugation orbits of these matrices
um
you know they they sort of partition
this this tangent space into
sets of matrices with the same
eigenvalues
right so this is going to be the
analogous thing to say p1 which is the
set of all matrices with one pot one
eigenvalue one the rest zero or looking
at these unitary orbits of other
hermitian matrices this is going to be
sort of
what what is going to generalize here
we'll get to that
um okay
so we we had this we have this group we
have this nice tangent space the group
acts very naturally on this tangent
space
okay what about the skew permission
matrices themselves their matrices maybe
they can sort of act on themselves or
something like this
and the problem here is these aren't a
group so you can't maybe
get some action exactly but you can do
something which is kind of interesting
which is basically given by this matrix
commutator here
okay and the point of this line here is
just to show that this actually
preserves skew permission matrices
okay and so this this is a little bit
you know out of thin air i'm just kind
of pulling this out of nowhere if you
know where i'm going i mean you know
where this is where this is coming from
but the point that i'm trying to make
here
is that
and before i guess before i say that the
point i'm trying to make here is that
there there seem to be these kind of
really nice actions that you can do
coming from the group or the or the
tangent space on on the tangent space
that preserve it like kind of like you
know either the group it's a very nice
group action or this thing maybe has
some nice properties maybe we'll get the
c and in fact one way to even view this
if you kind of squint at this for just a
little bit right and you think of you
um right instead of putting you and you
inverse here you maybe put a path
through unitaries and and the inverse
you could kind of see how this
becomes sort of like a product rule on
this right where maybe on you know for
the i first take derivative of this
and then i take derivative of this when
i take this derivative this y shows up
and when i take this derivative maybe
this minus one comes down and the y is
over here
okay so this actually is quite related
to this group action and we'll see that
a little more formally later
okay but again like continuing this this
theme what's happening on this on this
unitary group is we have these two
structures and they continue to combine
to give these symmetries the point is we
have this we have this group
is that a question okay we have this uh
we have this group we have this manifold
structure and putting them together it
leads us to you know
actions on this tangent space it gives
us this kind of partitioning of the
tangent space into orbits based on
eigenvalues these are exactly the sort
of things that nishith was looking at in
the previous talk and so
as we start to the point i'm trying to
i'm trying to make you feel that these
that kind of there's a lot here and that
you know maybe you'll start to feel that
this sort of has to generalize right i'm
kind of pulling things out of the air
but it seems very nice it seems very
kind of structural
and so let's see let's see what else we
can get here okay so the last thing
before i move on to talking exactly
about why
all of these things arise
uh so nicely what like where the where
the acts where this structure actually
comes from
let me talk about one more thing
which is this inner product so
throughout these you know these two
everything that she was talking about
and in particular at least to these two
problems there was always this special
inner product that was that was around
it was always this forbidious inner
product and here's how you can how you
can define it
okay
and if you restrict this to skew
remission matrices this is just i mean
this is a very simple computation but
right what do we know we know that y
star is minus y so you get a minus sign
out here and you just get this bi-linear
form
x y
so minus trace of x y
and this ends up being some inner
product on
uh
on this tangent space
okay and so okay fine right we have this
great inner product what's what's the
point of this
you sort of added a minus sign and okay
great
and and the point i want to make with
this is there's some really nice things
that we saw in the sheesh's talk which i
will i will you know
give you here again
so the first point is right if you if
you look at this conjugation action of u
on
each of these
elements of the tangent space here
right that just boils down to just the
inner product between these two so this
thing is invariant under the unitary
group
and even more this kind of mystical
commutator i talked about in the last
slide
also has a similar property so if you
kind of put a commutator over here you
can sort of switch it to the other side
the cost of a minus sign
okay so this is kind of a whirlwind of
features of the unitary group
the symmetries that they
that the unitary group provides on its
tangent space
some operations this inner product
that's really nice
so what's really going on
okay
so this is where lea theory comes in
and the point is that a lead group
generalizes the unitary group in a very
natural way
as we have seen through many of the
talks here basically what it is is it's
a it's a group
and a manifold such that the group
operations are smooth okay so this this
phrase i used before that the structures
are compatible
it's just you have these two structures
you put them together they work nicely
together that's what a lead group is
okay and here are some some examples of
the kind of the matrix lead groups so
these are ones that arise you know these
are some subset of matrices
um we saw these
in the morning talks
this one is the one that i'll be
focusing on mainly
um but the stuff that i will be talking
about will also apply to
uh
these the unitaries here
uh these rotation matrices these unitary
sympathetics if you you care about those
um but there are a number of these
things
and there's actually you know i mean you
can think of any kind of closed
subgroup of any of these matrix groups
and you're always going to get
um some lead group
and you know i kind of mentioned before
right we had these we had these two
subgroups that we talked about a little
bit
um and it turns out they're actually lee
subgroups so all that means is you have
this set of invertible complex matrices
um and you look at un the manifold
structure is kind of inherited from this
it's a subgroup that comes that is a
subgroup of this of this general linear
group and the same thing goes for this
compact torus here as well
and in fact all major troops actually
are just these subgroups of george
okay so we have this unitary group now
we're looking at a bunch of groups so
how exactly
does what we did with the unitary group
kind of convert
to
a general lead group
okay and and the point i'm going to make
on this slide is that these ideas that
we looked at with the unitary group and
the symmetries we saw in the tangent
space they generalized to any group
g with with identity e
but of course the the kind of the
problem there is you know right all the
all the leaders i listed on the previous
page role matrix groups but the
definition was just you know a manifold
structure and a group structure a priori
there's not any matrices going on
there's no sense of conjugation
and so we need some way to to generalize
this notion of conjugation
and there is a way to do that
so
what we can do is
instead of looking at the conjugation
action of g on its standard space which
a priori doesn't really make sense right
now
we can actually look at the action of g
on itself via conjugation so i just fix
some element g of the group and i look
at this map which just sends h
to the conjugate of h right this is this
is a group this is just multiplication
in the group so that's that's fine we
can do this and we know that it's smooth
by the compatibility assumption
and what you can do is now okay you this
is some smooth map between lead groups
so we can do calculus
we can take the differential
at the at the identity
and what that is going to give us is
it's going to give us some map from the
tangent space of the identity to to
itself
that basically sort of looks like
conjugation right it's sort of
conjugation of some path
with a derivative so
the point here is and you know this is
called the adjoint action and you heard
nasheed use this phrase adjoint orbits
uh last time and it comes from this
because
even though we don't a priori know that
this tangent space is made up of
matrices there is a way to generalize
this idea of conjugation
and the way that it's the way it's
generalized is like this and it's called
the the adjoint action
okay so we have now this conjugation
action
um
you know conjugation in quotes action of
g on its tangent space
and i'm not going to really say this but
the point is it turns out what you can
you can further do is basically you know
reinterpret this in some kind of
interesting way and further take another
derivative and get this
kind of algebra adjoint action
which
the point of me saying this is just that
right okay so it's very clear to us that
this that this thing here if i were to
if i were to look at the unitary group
would end up just being this conjugation
that's what we expect but then this kind
of
taking derivative of this
function ends up getting us this this
matrix commutator and so the point here
is that even though right matrix
commutator doesn't make sense
for things that aren't matrices
conjugation doesn't necessarily make
sense for things that aren't matrices
there are still ways to generalize this
and so for all kind of intensive
purposes we can think about um this
conjugation action
like happening like we have a group and
it has this adjoint or conjugation
action on its standard space and the
same for this sort of commutator action
and
as i've kind of noted here
before these conjugation orbits that we
looked we looked at before which were
you took some skewer mission matrix and
you looked at
you know all
you conjugated it by every unitary
matrix and got all matrices with the
same eigenvalues you can now kind of
generalize this notion to the notion of
an adjoint orbit which is just going to
be you take some element x of your
tangent space and you act on it by the
whole group
okay
so we have right we have this unitary
group with this tangent space
we we generalize this notion to to lead
groups in general with basically using
time some you know some standard kind of
manifold calculus we end up getting
roughly speaking um a generalization of
these of these adjoint maps oh sorry i
have these conjugation and commutator
maps which are called the adjoints
and we have this generalization of
hermitian orbit
uh which is called adjoint orbit
okay and and so this last slide which
which is just going to be just to kind
of close the loop here um we won't use
we'll use a little bit of what's on this
slide but not too much right we now have
the standard space
at the identity of this lead group and
it has all sorts of structure on it
there are all sorts of operations so we
should just give it a name and what it
is called is a lead algebra and so the
idea is a lie algebra then is just some
vector space that has this what's called
a lead bracket on it that has some
properties
but essentially this lee bracket all it
ends all it really is is this commutator
uh that we saw earlier so this is sort
of an abstract way to define the
algebras uh we we constructed a lee
algebra from you know taking a group
looking at its tangent space coming up
with these operations but there's also
an abstract way to define it like this
yeah
and so the the the point of me saying
this slide the reason i even bring this
up is mainly for this bilinearity
property i really just want this the
bilinearity of this of this kind of
algebra adjoint action or this
commutator it's pretty easy to see from
the commutator that it's bi-linear
because
the last thing we sort of need to
generalize right we we have this we have
this tangent space we have the actions
on it and now we need to generalize this
inner product
and very similar with uh the previous
situation the problem with generalizing
this inner product is before we used
this forbiddenious inner product which
had this trace
okay
and the problem is we don't we don't
have we don't have trace here anymore
right these are not matrices we can't
just take tricks
but the point is what we can do is we
can think of this
adjoint action right this is some linear
operator so if i fix y
in one
input of this commutator
and i let this x input vary this is some
linear map
right it's some linear map on the on the
lead algebra well i guess i forgot to
mention this i really should so we were
using um we were using this tangent
space notation and now that we're kind
of like the the proper lead algebra
notation is this sort of
um i don't know how like kind of script
g and so these these are sort of now
identified and so this this map here
this uh
this linear adjoint map is a map on on
the lee algebra and because we have this
what we can do is we can now say okay
well we don't have trace
of the elements of the algebra itself
but what i can do is i can think of an
element of the lead algebra as this
linear map
i can compose those linear maps
that's going to give me some other
linear map on the lea algebra g and i
can take trace of that
okay and before we had this minus sign
but i just sort of moved it over here
because the point is this thing has a
very special name with which
she talked about it's called the killing
form
named after this guy uh killing
and and the key fact that we're going to
use here and the kind of the real reason
why we restrict to compact groups a lot
here um and why a lot of these results
kind of only make sense for compact
groups is because this thing is negative
definite whenever g is compact now this
is there's a little caveat here i'm kind
of throwing some technical things
away but it doesn't really matter for us
so
um i'm not really going to worry about
it
but this is kind of the point like uh
whenever g is compact you get this
negative definite and in fact if you
want it to be negative definite you have
to have a compact group that you started
with
okay and and further as you might guess
this killing form has these same
invariance properties we talked about
before
okay
so that was kind of a whirlwind um going
through
this structure of the unitary group
talking about how it generalized to lead
groups in general how we came up with
this lee algebra we have this inner
product whenever our group is compact we
have these adjoint orbits we have this
sort of conjugation action okay so maybe
now we have these tools that we need to
get back to our two original problems so
that's what i'm going to do now
okay so let's first talk about the
optimization
problem so here is the problem
okay we had this hermitian y
and we wanted to compute the minimum
eigenvalue of y
and we wrote it a number of ways but
these were two of them
one was we minimized over the unitary
group and conjugated this
what sheath called this capital e1
matrix this is just the matrix with one
in the top left zeros everywhere else
okay you can minimize this inner product
over unitaries or you can just minimize
this inner product over all rank one pst
projections
this is this all the set of all piece
here is exactly what you get from this
conjugation
okay
and so what was
used for this is this sure horn theorem
and for us what this said and i i think
i said nashith used this in a slightly
different way but i'm going to use it
for p1 here what this says is if you
take this p1 the set of all rank 1 psd
projections and you look at the set of
all possible diagonal vectors that come
from those matrices
you just get the standard simplex
um and this n here is the dimension of
the simplex so these are the set of all
length end vectors with non-negative
entries that sum to one
so this was a crucial feature then the
sheath used crucial theorem that nishith
used to prove this
okay and in particular if we make y
diagonal we can see exactly how this
gets used
right because the point is what well if
y is diagonal
okay then the off diagonal elements of p
don't really matter to this inner
product so i can just restrict to the
diagonal entries of p
and strict to the restrict to the
diagonal entries of y
and in fact now i can write this
minimization problem as just a
minimization problem over the simplex
now these are the things these are the
diagonal entries of these
okay
and the the whole thing here was that we
had this optimization problem over some
some adjoint orbit which is some
non-convex thing and it ends up being
equivalent to a linear optimization
problem on a convex polytope
okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take this problem we're going to try to
phrase it in this language we just
looked at
okay and we're gonna do it for you n and
then see if we can generalize from there
so the first thing is a comment i made
earlier right so everything we had
before was skew hermitian matrices that
was the lead algebra of the unitary
group
okay
um
and basically it does this is like kind
of an inconsequential thing this is
equivalent to emission matrices using
this map right here for every hermitian
matrix you can multiply by i to get
something skew permission and you can
also go back in the same way
um and the point is like you know maybe
maybe there'll be some minus sign that
comes out because now you're looking at
an inner product of things with i next
to it or something like this but
uh up to that there's there's really no
distinction here in terms of the
optimization
okay
and of course as you might guess the
other thing is we have this fabrinius
inner product right which is written
down like this and so instead of this we
can just replace it with this killing
form right in fact this is precisely the
killing form for the lead algebra of the
unitary group skew permission matrices
and the last thing which i also kind of
hinted at before
i can rephrase this p1
as the unitary group applied to
this matrix here
just a set of all conjugates of e1e1
transpose and that's going to be an
adjoint orbit of un so this conjugation
action is the adjoint action of this
group and so this is one of these
adjoint orbits
and this notion as we saw extends to
other lead groups
okay so we have all this set up that's
great okay now we want to can we
generalize this to other compact lead
groups well there are still a few things
missing that we have not been able to
generalize
so
here's our optimization problem again
i've now just put this simplex uh form
on the right hand side here right for
some diagonal y we want to compute this
minimum eigenvalue
okay and what is left so
this is what we have so far if we have a
compact lead group g with its lead
algebra you know
script g
down the un side we have these skew
permission matrices
a hermitian or skew formation y that's
just an element of the lead algebra we
have this p1 which is this conjugate of
e1e1 transpose well that's just an
adjoint orbit of g
and we have this inner product which is
just the negated killing form on g
but the things we are missing are still
these two notions the notion of a
diagonal matrix right we started off
with this diagonal y so that we could do
this
and also the notion of the standard
simplex how do these generalize
okay and so the first thing we're going
to see is how diagonal matrices
generalize
and the point is we're going to go back
to this subgroup that i keep kind of
mentioning for un this compact taurus
and the point is for this compact taurus
is that it's some subgroup of the
unitary group but it also is
corresponding to some sub-algebra of
uh the unitary lee algebra this this is
not a big deal um it just means that the
bracket is sort of trivial on this on
this sub-algebra
on this subspace but it doesn't really
matter the point is that you have this
kind of connection between diagonal
matrix here and diagonal matrices here
so in in
in un at least in this you in this uh
the you in we have some way of maybe
talking about diagonal matrices sort of
without referring to the words diagonal
right we have this abelian sub algebra
and in fact if you just say a maximal
abelian subalgebra okay which is going
to correspond to some maximal taurus in
the unitary group
this has a name which is called a carton
sub-algebra now this
typically carton sub-algebras are used
for another context
and this is not how you would define
them in that context but in the compact
case this is sort of a
fair definition so i will stick with
that but the point is what we've done
here is we've found some way to talk
about the diagonal matrices in the
unitary lead algebra without actually
saying the words diagonal
so now we can ask this question okay so
we have this we have this diagonal kind
of these diagonal matrices okay we can
still think of them as diagonal matrices
do they have some symmetries
and one thing we can say is okay well
let's suppose i want to con act by
conjugation from the unitary group
on this sub algebra t
well if i want to preserve the set of
all diagonal matrices one thing i can
act by certainly is a diagonal matrix so
if i conjugate something diagonal by
something diagonal in here i'll get
another diagonal matrix
but the other thing that preserves this
space
are the permutation matrices so if i
conjugate a diagonal matrix by a
permutation matrix it just permutes the
entries
and so the idea here then is this sort
of thing happens kind of for any uh
maximal abelian sub-algebra of a compact
lea you know lee algebra like this and
we can give a name to this kind of
discrete group that emerges we can call
it the vial group and it's always going
to be some discrete thing it's always
going to be finite and it can be defined
for all lead groups g i unfortunately
won't get to say much more about this
it's very important in the kind of
classification of lead groups
and a number of other kind of structural
results you want to make but for us it's
going to be this kind of discrete
symmetry group that arises in this way
okay so
right we figured out diagonal matrix
matrices we have this standard simplex
oh sorry we have this vowel group now
can we can we somehow get this standard
simplex to come out
okay so this is where this cost
convexity theorem comes up that the
sheath was referring to
so what did we have before let's
reiterate the sherhorn theorem
what it says is that you take some
conjugation orbit of a hermitian matrix
h
you look at all the diagonal vectors you
get a convex polytope that's the most
general form of the theorem
for the cosine convexity theorem
what we do is we now are going to
generalize all these things that appear
in the sherhorn theorem
do something
that comes up in a lead algebra so we
have diagonal matrices being this carton
sub-algebra we have the killing form
being this minus trace
um we have this
diag map here that's going to end up
being this is the generalization of that
it's just going to be the projection
onto the carton sub-algebra we have this
vowel group and now we pick some element
uh x in the carton sub-algebra which for
us we're sort of restricting diagonal
hermitian h here
and the theorem we end up getting is
this and let me parse this let me try to
say what this says in the case of the
unitary group what this says is if you
you if g is the unitary group it says
okay
i look at the unitary conjugation orbit
of some diagonal permission matrix and i
intersect it with diagonal matrices
that is just going to be the
permutations of the diagonal of the
original matrix
okay so you you look at this conjugation
orbit
you get a bunch of information matrices
the only diagonal ones are the ones
where you permute the eigenvalues
and this is the one that's more
important this one says that if i take
this unitary orbit and i project it onto
the diagonal
the thing i get is just the convex hole
of this vial group orbit and since the
vowel group is a finite group
i know that this orbit is something
finite so this is the convex hole of a
finite number of points
and so this theorem exactly says that if
you take some adjoint orbit and you
project it onto this carton sub-algebra
which is essentially the same thing you
know it's sort of emulating diagonal
matrices you get some convex hole of a
finite number of points which is exactly
a convex polytope this is exactly what
we want
so this is how the shorehorn theorem
generalizes
and the way that that this then allows
us to do linear optimization
[Music]
is as follows so we have this x which is
diagonal or is in this carton
sub-algebra we now have some z that's
again one of these diagonal slash carton
elements
and this is the problem we want to solve
right this is just minimizing over the
adjoint orbit
some uh
some uh
linear function here
and so what do we do well the first
thing we can note is that since this is
right in t
it makes no difference if i project this
y
onto t
right this is an orthogonal projection
so this is not going to affect the inner
product
but now what i have is that i have that
i'm minimizing over the orbit of pi of
that element
this is the same thing as just
minimizing over this
okay and i know that this is equal to
this so i can just replace
the domain here
so now i'm minimizing over some convex
polytope this linear function
and then at the very end
right i can actually remove this if i
want and now i'm minimizing over some
discrete set so i can stop here and just
say that minimization over a convex
polytope is equivalent to minimization
over the orbit or i can also think of it
as a discrete you know minimization
problem over a discrete set of points
okay and so the point of this is right
we have the sherhorn theorem it says
something very nice
and it turns out that that very nice
thing extend far beyond
this rank one projections we started
with and this minimum eigenvalue that we
wanted to compute
okay
so next i'm going to move on to the um
to the uh
sampling part where we're trying to
compute this partition function
does anyone have any questions before i
do that i probably should have asked
that
earlier
you just have a minimization over some
discrete set of a linear function i mean
what are are there other examples of uh
you know interesting while loops that
are like combinatorial objects that you
want to
optimize over i guess you get the
uh pre permeate heater there um do you
get anything else so yeah so permutation
will come out here from just the normal
uh vertices on the right side yeah yeah
this is just the the the vertices of the
it'll end up being yeah the vertices of
the polygon so you definitely get the
prometakedron i mean the other vowel
groups that show up are things like this
uh i don't remember the name of it but
it's like um
ortho
hyper symmetric group it's like it's
like a symmetric group with like a z2
kind of acting on it it's two copies of
the symmetric group that sort of
interact i've never really thought about
what what one can get from optimizing uh
over whatever the convex hole of that
would be um
yeah i guess uh that's a that's a fair
question that i haven't really thought
about um but yeah the
definitely if you were just looking for
the polytope it's here whereas this is
just the vertices what you're saying
yeah i was wondering like would you
sometimes get
things that are clearly hard to optimize
over like
uh
yeah i mean i i would
i would doubt it
because i would expect kind of
maybe this method
to
hmm
i don't know actually
i think the science conversation basis
is
interesting
so you add just exact compensation
matrices but you can take all sides
it's another
slide without
not that i see an application by the way
do you know what is the
algebra for which is what the output for
which this is
i want to say it's the symplectic group
but i but i actually don't know actually
not now you asked this
um
i don't i can't i can't remember the
difference actually between the
orthogonal for one of them from it's
like the orthogonal group has the sign
permutations or the syntactic group does
and then the other one has something
slightly different and i can't quite
remember
i also have a question about um so with
this like abstract of homologism um is
it
does it make it easier to like come up
with something
for this because for example for the
email id value like for this very
special case we know like there's a
uh algorithm
so i was just wondering like with this
like formalism
uh with like the algebra you cannot call
without going for this problem
so there are definitely algorithms for
certain optimization problems on uh
if you kind of go to this more general
lee algebra framework the ones i'm
familiar with are actually not this is
sort of more of a toy problem just to
kind of without well kind of to show you
what like something very basic that
could be done um but there are certain
the ones that i'm more familiar with are
like uh you can ask to
do some kind of relative entropy
programming over adjoint orbits of of
lead groups
um and nishida and i have some work
about that so that's like some
optimization problem over some some
agile orbit
um
that you can
you can you it relies on this coastline
convexity theorem for certain for
certain aspects of it you have to at
some point go
go to you know show that the uh you
basically have to show at some point
that the op the optimum occurs like at
an extreme point like this but you don't
it doesn't really this doesn't give you
an algorithm it just sort of shows you
that
like
you know you expect to get some kind of
extreme point you hope that to be the
case and then this theorem says that it
doesn't really aid with the algorithm
though
um but in terms of algorithms coming
from this i'm not i'm not sure
sorry another maybe like a dumb question
and related to this one is it clear that
i guess the that was the uh the
optimization problem that nasheed looked
at and now let's look at the sampling
problem
okay this one you know as you might as
you might guess this one is going to be
a little bit less
clear maybe as to how exactly
the results come from kind of these
these added
structures right with this other one
okay maybe you could sort of squint and
see okay there's there's some kind of
polytope here when i look at some some
analogy to diagonal matrices
and then we can do linear optimization
okay
uh this one is going to be a little bit
harder as because as you might guess the
the you know from the result that we saw
in ishi's talk it's a lot more kind of
magical what what happens uh and
unfortunately i won't be able to say too
much and most of the proofs i know of
these results are pretty uh
are pretty long-winded um so i won't be
able to go into it too much but i'll try
to give you a sense
okay so here's the here's the sampling
problem
uh that we looked at before we had some
permission matrix y and we wanted to
sample from this density that's very
similar to you know the thing we're
optimizing so we have this density
function on the complex unit sphere
or we have this density function on the
set of rank one projections this adjoint
orbit
okay and the the formula that nishith
showed us was the following right so if
i have some permission y with distinct
eigenvalues then i have i can look at
this integral over the rank one
projections it turns out to be some
integral over the standard simplex and
rn and then that actually has some
really nice
very small sum formula
okay so sheath showed us this
and the point is that right we get some
exact formula for the partition function
and this basically you know like morally
should enable sampling this is actually
not always true in all the cases we have
here but sort of the idea is if you can
get some partition function you think
that you should be able to sample so the
first thing we're going to try to do
here is is see if we can generalize this
partition function formula
and so we're going to ask the same
question can we phrase this in leap
theory language language and the first
few things are exactly the things we saw
before right we have this this p1 this
is just some adjoint orbit of un if you
think about right we're going to still
do this thing where her mission and sue
her mission are basically identified we
have this uh
this inner product
which is just the trace here um
with a with a minus sign and this is
this killing form for the sku permission
matrices and so that's exactly what's
going to play the role of this
and what's going to be this adjoint
orbit here okay but what is left over
for us
is this uh this measure mu 1 here that
we haven't really talked about we've
even talked about this simplex a little
bit
right we know maybe how you might expect
matrices to become vectors and there'd
be a simplex showing up we don't maybe
exactly know how that's going to work
but
we sort of have some idea of that the
thing that we're missing is just this
measure so let's talk about where this
measure comes from
okay so in sheath's talk this measure mu
1
is some some measure on this adjoint
orbit on the set of rank 1 projections
that was invariant under the conjugation
action
of u n and all that means is if i take
some integral over some function
and i conjugate the function by u
it's just equal to if i were to take the
integral
over the function without the
conjugation so these are equal for all
integrable functions
and the point here is that
if you take a compact lead group
that it has some very special
conjugation invariant measure called the
har measure
and
i will tell you the the way to construct
this for the unitary group
it's it's not so hard right the unitary
group you want to have some some measure
on the unitary group that's invariant
under conjugation by unitaries
and so
well what are what's like kind of the
most natural thing you can think of the
unitary group you can think of it as
matrices whose whose columns are are
orthonormal bases of
some complex vector space and so one way
to come up with
uh one way to sample really naturally
from the unitary group is to just say
okay i'm going to pick some random
vectors and see the n i'm going to use
gram schmidt orthonormalization
i'm going to then take all those vectors
and put them as columns in some matrix
and it turns out this this you know
sampling from that right that's going to
give me some unitary matrix and that
process actually samples from this hard
measure okay so this hard measure at
least in the unitary group is very
natural and um it's it's
i don't know similar constructions for
the other groups um but it's this this
theorem of power has been known for for
quite some time so you have this very
natural invariant measure on the group
and what you can what the point is is
that this this invariant measure then
sort of
uh induces an invariant measure on every
adjoint orbit
and this is a this is also a very
straightforward fact
um
it's just using the fact that um
i won't even say anything about it
but the point is it induces some measure
hard measure on on the on the orbits
like this so now i have right if i take
some some integral over the orbit and i
act on the input to this function by
some group element it's the same as if i
didn't
and in fact this measure mu 1 is exactly
what you get whenever you do this
process with unitary group and with this
adjoint orbit p1
so now we have this way to generalize at
least this expression that we care about
over here which is basically as follows
so before i had this expression this is
what i wanted to write down a formula
for and so now i can replace this by
some adjoint orbit i can replace this by
this killing form and then i can replace
this measure by this har measure that i
get from the group
so now how what formulas can i get now
from this
okay so this this next
page
is going to is going to talk about these
formulas
um the the kind of slide after hopefully
i'll give you a little motivation for
why you'd expect
at least one of them to work out
um so here was our original formula
talked about
and so now here is this really general
horizontal formula that he
said that he hoped that i would that i
would write down it's pretty difficult
to write down um because of there's kind
of a lot of things that i don't want to
say um but basically this is sort of the
expression here you have some compact
lead group same caveats as before
um you have some it's associated lead
algebra you have your carton sub-algebra
so this was your notion of diagonal
matrix you have your vowel group
and you have some diagonal elements
and then from there you can write this
integral that we care about right this
is this is a version of this we can
write it as this finite sum formula like
this
so it's some constant which is sort of
like factorials and there's some
vandermonde determinant uh of the uh
uh related to the the these these
elements here
and then you have this sum over the vial
group
and this you know again unfortunately
there's just a lot of notation here uh
that that i won't really be able to go
into but the way you want to think about
this is you have some sum over this
finite vial group the vowel group can be
very large right we know that s n has n
factorial elements you have some sine
term
of the element of the va group that
you're that you're summing over and then
you have something very similar to what
showed up
in the integral here except instead of
instead of having some z coming from the
adjoint orbit
you're acting on your your x
by this element of the vowel group
and the point is if you think of w as
being sn so if you think of the unitary
group case
okay so
let me just let me just write this down
if you think of the unitary group case
well what's happening here you're having
a sum over the symmetric group this is
some kind of sign right this is going to
be like the minus one of the sine of
permutation and you have some
exponential here which you can write as
sum product
and the point is if you kind of put this
all together this is basically just an
expression for the determinant
so that's how you get this hci z formula
that he wrote down at least when
restricted to uh
this adjoint orbit he wrote a slightly
different form of it but these forms are
equivalent
you basically get this determinant up
here you get some vandomans down here
and you get some factorials here
and the point of this is that she
pointed out is that this gives you some
finite sum formula for any adjoint orbit
of any compact league group
and the point is from for matrix groups
for most of the groups that we had in
that big list um it pretty much always
boils down to a sum of of like i think
two or less determinants maybe maybe
there's three one time i can't remember
it's not very obvious from this how you
should be able to get determinants but
it's it's sort of you go and do the case
work for kind of the cases that you know
you might care about like say symplectic
or orthogonal group you can get some
kind of determinate formula here
okay and so
there's kind of two remaining questions
with this uh with this the first one is
okay now we have some partition function
formula for these adjoint orbits
okay
it looks like some it looks like some
determinant in most of the nice cases it
looks like some determinant
so there's two outstanding things the
first thing is how what about this thing
here this simplex formula we did we sort
of skipped that right we went straight
from this to this
and the second thing which is very
related to this fact that we don't have
a simplex formula yet
is this kind of thing i said a few
slides ago where i said like basically
we have a partition function that should
imply that we can sample right why
doesn't having this partition function
imply that we can sample
and so i'm going to talk about both of
those things at the same time and we're
going to see exactly how this uh
how this comes about in a more general
case
so
the first thing i'll say is i'm only
going to be able to talk about this kind
of picture for you n because i don't
really know the picture very well for
other compact groups so this is like one
of the open problems of this of this
talk
um
and i'll list that kind of at the end
slide but let's let's just take a look
at this expression again right we we
sort of showed the generalization of
these outer two how do we get this
middle thing
okay so here here's like the cheapest
thing you can do right
we know that this
simplex is the thing that comes out of
applying the cosine convexity theorem or
the short horn theorem to this p1 right
that's what we saw in the previous
slides so why don't we just apply this
cosine convexity theorem to some general
unitary orbit right whatever orbit i
decide to put here i'm going to get some
you know projection that's going to be
some convex hole and i'm going to get
some you know permutation or some kind
of polytope here maybe i can just
integrate over that and everything will
be great
so that would be the idea that would be
the hope
but unfortunately that is is not true
and basically to make this equal you
need to add and nashif pointed made a
comment about this you need to add a
piecewise polynomial function here that
that i have not been able to understand
and i don't really know anyone who who
could i don't know i mean if if someone
knows how to compute it i would i would
love to i would love to hear that
algorithm but i don't know what it is
and we couldn't figure it out
um and so because of that this is you
know we sort of had to try something
different
okay and this is this rayleigh map that
nishis was talking about so here's the
thing that we tried that was different
so we're gonna we're gonna talk about
this map script r
okay
and the point is you're gonna you're
gonna plug in some here's just gonna be
some permission matrix and it's going to
output
a big
kind of triangle of numbers and here's
how it goes so
whatever j is i'm going to look at the
leading principle j by j sub matrix and
i'm just going to list the eigenvalues
of that sub matrix
so when j equals 3
i'm going to list the eigenvalues of the
whole matrix when j equals 2 i'm going
to list the eigenvalues of this top 2x2
matrix and when j equals 1 there's just
going to be one value which is this
upper diagonal entry
and so this is going to form some
triangle i'm going to have 3 elements
the top 2 below it and then one below
that and the reason why this is referred
to as the rayleigh map is because of
this kind of rayleigh interlacing or
rayleigh cauchy interlacing theorem
which basically just says what what this
says is that if i take the eigenvalues
of some matrix here
there's three of them and i look at the
eigenvalues of just a sub matrix that
has one less a principal sub matrix with
one lesser own column
then the eigenvalues
of this smaller matrix are interlaced
between the eigenvalues of the larger
matrix so
you know the first the first eigenvalue
is somewhere in between the first and
second eigenvalue of the bigger matrix
the second eigenvalue is somewhere in
between the second and third eigenvalue
of the bigger matrix so we get all these
inequalities and you can sort of
inductively get all these inequalities
on all these successive sub matrices of
um
this this matrix z you started with or i
guess x
and the point is these inequalities
right i mean these are just a set of
inequalities they cut out some polytope
it's called the galvan polytope but the
but the great fact is not only that
but now if you take your entire unitary
orbit and you apply this rayleigh map to
it you actually get the whole polytope
all right so this is somehow very
similar to the sherhorn theorem except
now we have this kind of way more
complicated rayleigh map
and the point is then
that also further beyond that we have
that if we if we take this measure that
we started off with this measure on the
adjoint orbit here and we push it
forward through this r we now actually
get labeg measure so this sort of is
better emulating this picture here
right we started with this we wanted to
kind of push this exponential density
forward we get some exponential things
times the bag and that picture
persists whenever you choose this
rayleigh map like this
so this is one way that you can prove
this hcis partition function formula but
another nice thing about this is
this means that sampling from
um these these adjoint orbits these
unitary orbits
are uh are sort of equivalent to
sampling from this galvan polytope
according to this exponential density
that's going to look something like this
it's going to be a little bit different
but
we can it's sort of we can sample from
the polytope according to this density
and then we can somehow transfer that
sample back to the adjoint orbit
okay and this is exactly
the only sampling algorithm i know to
try to actually use this part the
partition function formula we have here
to actually sample from these adjoint
orbits
just because we have this partition
function formula i don't actually know
how to just use that to sample but this
fact that it's connected to some
polytope that's the thing that i know
how to use to be able to actually sample
sample from the polytope bring it back
to the orbit
what do you mean by bringing it back
yeah so uh
well no it's gonna be right it's uh i
mean i'll sample from from the set of
all triangles
so this gt polytope is the set of all
like
collections of of of successive
interlacing eigenvalues
that's some polytope that has some
really nice measure on it i can sample
from that using some polytube sampling
algorithm
and coming back which i i
we can maybe yeah we can talk about it
after i'm i should probably go ahead and
finish the talk here but if you have if
you want me to talk about that i can
there's sort of a way to kind of
inductively construct a unitary uh sorry
uh
conductively inductively construct some
element of this adjoint orbit by sort of
using kind of
each row of this triangle you sort of
you sort of
but you know i mean like i guess the
cheapest thing to say is you like the
row that's length one is going to
completely determine this this this
upper left entry here and now you have
some
pair of eigenvalues for this matrix and
there's some way to construct some some
two by two matrix from that and you kind
of keep doing this and the point is
somehow at every step there's like a
about like a compact tourist action
acting on these new off-diagonal entries
and that's sort of the degree of freedom
you have in fact there's a way to think
of this rayleigh map as a
as a type of moment map just with
a bunch of different compact tourist
actions kind of at different stages
of the construction of this triangle um
that's also something i don't i i don't
know that sort of rigorously i just know
that there's you can do something like
that um and i think you can interpret it
kind of in the in the usual way as some
kind of more complicated moment but but
anyway that's how you would you would
take some triangle and you would try to
bring it back
um okay so yeah i think i'm over time
here so let me just throw up the last
slide which just kind of says some of
the things that have been said over the
over the course of this here so we saw
uh we saw these two problems and she's
talked about um
in this talk we kind of saw how these
the symmetries that were showing up in
these problems come from lead theory and
the point is that these symmetries allow
for you know the powerful use of the use
of powerful tools in particular
transferring non-convex problems to
complex polytopes
and then the open questions are the
things i kind of i kind of mentioned
right so we have these for for instance
okay you know we talked about a lot of
things for aging over to un but what
about other compact lead groups we have
this hc formula but i don't know how to
sample for things beyond the unitary
group
especially this would be interesting um
right even even doing these sampling
from the from the real unit sphere there
might be some well i guess for the units
here maybe there are some algorithms but
like more general orbits it's it's
unclear
and then also more general orbits even
beyond adjoining orbits so
these these adjoin orbits of compact
groups are actually symplectic and so
maybe you can sort of generalize these
to other symplectic orbits or maybe
romanian orbits i'm not i'm not really
sure i haven't haven't thought about
that too much so
um anyway thanks a lot uh and as as as i
pointed at the beginning here are the
notes for
the sheath and my talk
[Applause]
questions
i guess i didn't quite
reach clarity on the sampling from the
political but we can take it offline
here i just want to mention one thing
there is work in pure matrix series
which is
that allows you giving a given a point
in that polyphone allows you to
construct a big matrix so that its
nested sequence of principles of
matrices has the correct
spectra yeah so this probably is related
to how you do something
yeah yeah in fact i mean
like whenever we so uh
my most recent paper within the sheath
and colin mcswiggen we do we kind of
demonstrate this sampling algorithm and
you know it was one of these things
where when we were working on it we just
tried to come up with something that'll
work and i think by the time we figured
out what would work to come back we
found some other papers that kind of do
this so i that is not surprising in fact
maybe we might even miss the reference
honestly if you have the explicit
reference where that's like really
written down
i'd love to see it yeah i mean it just
means that would probably make your life
easier yeah yeah yeah
and then just interpret it in the
context of your problem
and like i say i'm i'm sure someone it's
not a very complicated
thing to go about like once you kind of
see it it's very clear what you what you
need to do um so it's not surprising to
me that maybe someone had come up with
that already
you also need uh you need to go back to
a uniform at random
pretty image so maybe it's not totally
oh yeah oh actually that's that's that
is a good question is it is it just a
way to construct a matrix
i do not recall the details but yeah
it's worth looking at yeah yeah
absolutely
it accomplishes basically what you need
or you want to tweak it just a little
bit yeah and also i mean like these
these the sampling algorithms for
uh for these other groups
coming back is also a little unclear
what to do so it'd be maybe if they do
it for like
real symmetric matrices or something
that would also be pretty interesting
so you didn't mention the contract uh
example that's the left what about the
life can you do it so not do it we know
what's the analog of uh
yeah no you don't
you get a you get a semi simple one you
get a uh like a non-degenerate killing
form but it won't be it won't be
indefinite either way
i have a couple of questions one was uh
could you go back to the
like formula the hci z and the the
like some of the
i mean
one thing i confused the left hand side
is like a positive uh
sum of exponential things and the
right-hand side has signs so how is that
even possible i mean yeah so i mean
i mean it's i mean the same thing kind
of goes for uh
this right
yeah i mean the the point is i think
that like
essentially this is something like you
know the key fact here is that a
vandermonde determinant
i believe is positive right i mean how
that has a particular sign
and and that's kind of this you know
you're gonna have some cancellation
there i mean you really i guess you
really won't because you're just it's a
bunch of products of things that will be
that would be positive both positive or
negative and this minus sign you know is
sort of it cancels out with some minus
sign that would come from this
determinant but the point is somehow
there is some cancellation like this
even though you have
kind of this determinant like formula
with a bunch of signs you end up sort of
always getting a positive number um and
i don't i don't exactly know
again beyond like vanderbond determinant
as like something i can say into the air
i don't exactly know why like why you
would why this sort of happens
um
but but it does i mean this is this is
what happens
um
i mean
but the sign up there uh that can
actually be negative
sometimes yeah like like if you expanded
the determinant right i mean these are
all positive numbers this is a positive
uh
entry matrix the determinant's going to
have a bunch of signs like exactly like
this but some books so again for some
reason i mean overall value is positive
yeah yeah exactly yeah this will always
be positive this will have some there'll
be some cancellation it's just
it will always be positive it's just
interesting i mean the left hand side is
also
like
log convex i guess
yeah and the right hand side is not
obviously at all
yeah but but i guess once you form this
determinant then it becomes clear
and again for most of the matrix groups
that
like you know the classic compact matrix
groups this will become some
determinants and it becomes pretty clear
that it's also going to be welcomed
but yeah but from this formula i don't i
don't know why i don't know if there's
some
in fact i don't know of any way of
working with this beyond converting it
into some determinant expressions and
then kind of moving on
all right let's uh thank josh again